foreign
from the West part of France from
Brittany and I'm very proud of it as
many britons are
I had a charismatic Professor Zhong ho
who got me interested in the European
project during my last year of studies
that was a turning point where I decided
to study iolo and I ended up doing a PhD
with him
even if it's not necessary obvious to
explain to our friends and families what
we are doing and how it's of interest to
them
the EU institutions have a huge impact
on our day-to-day loves us European
citizens
I've been a teaching rule for eight
years
working now on the digital
transformation of Industry
but before joining this position I was
coming from the public procurement world
and before that from the space world
jigro is definitely in the lead on the
main files and we are building Europe to
make it a better place to live to work
to invest
the interest of the unit is that it's
there is a diverse portfolio so we have
legislative proposals we have I would
say sort of program to manage which is a
single digital Gateway and we have also
a pillar about advocacy and promotion of
activities
[Music]
of course we are as an official we are
not the only ones responsible for a file
we have to work with many other
colleagues in the end a proposal is a
proposal from the commission but still
we can contribute to these major
initiatives
I think it's very rewarding we can make
a change
we can also try to bring solutions to
problems which are there and which have
a huge impact on on the ground
indeed discussing a lot now is the
council and we will start our activities
with the parliament soon
the commission is absolutely unique it
has a key role in our institutional
setup so it has a huge influence
after a certain number of years in the
commission you are no longer a lawyer or
an economist you become an official of
the commission with many experiences
I joined the commission 20 years ago
I think it's absolutely fantastic
it's a great environment to work in
where you can learn a lot about the
world about people about cultures
and
ultimately it's about us